Zeus can be described as an enigmatic
uncompromising and to many a very
controversial deity but whether you like
him or hate him there's no denying that
he's a driving force behind many of the
stories to emerge from Greek mythology
it's understandable to dislike someone
who causes so many conflicts and issues
but without these conflicts we have no
stories or at least none that aren't
linear and boring today's video will
cover a story that we don't know much
about other than a few speculative
accounts the story of what happened when
the Olympians attempted to rebel against
Zeus and take his throne before we
discuss the events itself we first need
to understand how the power structure
and hierarchy worked in Greek mythology
there's no doubt that the majority of
deities were extremely powerful but we
don't really know how powerful we
compared to one another because that
wasn't really something that was
measured back then at least not to the
extent that it is today well we need to
know who is the strongest and who would
defeat who in any given scenario to
establish a rulership and become king of
the gods it boiled down to who was brave
enough and confident enough to step
forward and take the throne which
doesn't necessarily mean the king or the
ruler was the most powerful we first see
this when Uranus is discerned by his
children and Cronus assumes the mantle
of King this began the cycle and the
prophecy that stated the ruler would be
dethroned by his children despite his
best efforts Cronus would eventually
suffer defeat to Zeus and his siblings
meaning the established power dynamic
was shattered and a new ruler would have
to step forward you can definitely argue
or debate as to which of Zeus Poseidon
or Hades was the most powerful deity in
which one of them should have been the
ruler but it was Zeus who freed his
siblings and ultimately defeated his
father and it was Zeus once again
through his own trickery to ensure that
he would rule the skies and claim the
throne atop Mount Olympus there were
several attempts to overthrow Zeus long
before the Olympians tried to do so
themselves with the majority of these
coming from Gaia the primordial goddess
of the earth and the mother of the
Titans but firstly when along with
Tartarus she created Typhon with the
sole intention of destroying the
Olympians and this was Lucy's first real
test as a leader and there are numerous
accounts of this story but in most of
them the gods chose to flee to Egypt
when faced with the daunting presence
that was typhoon
Zuse however chose to stay when after
abroad in battle where victory seemed
almost impossible zeus was finally able
to overcome typhoon and crush the first
rebellion against his rule similar to
the first rebellion the second came from
the Giants who were being encouraged by
Gaia seeking revenge for her children
their attack on Olympus was fairly
easily repelled by the Olympians who
also had help from Heracles needless to
say this rebellion was nowhere near the
level of the previous when it wouldn't
be into the coup of the Olympians that
the rule of Zeus would be threatened
once again so as we now move on to the
Olympian the coup we should take a look
at Zeus as a leader it's fairly
difficult to describe Zeus as a
tyrannical leader because the gods and
goddesses were free to do as they please
for the most part and Zeus certainly
didn't care about maintaining total
control of everything as important areas
such as law and justice were governed by
other deities those whose word would
still be final
this type of loose leadership could be
seen as a way of avoiding the prophecy
that stated he would be overthrown by
his children if you give your children
and fellow gods the freedom to do as
they please then assess likely they have
a reason to rebel and this most likely
would have worked but Zeus didn't
anticipate the driving factor behind the
rebellion his wife Hera so what exactly
would cause Hera to rebel against Zeus
Hera was largely regarded as the queen
of Olympus and the wife of Zeus you
could argue that she was the second in
power being married to Zeus however was
definitely no easy task as he took
several other wives and we know his
sexual appetite led to him having many
affairs and the way Hera would deal with
loose as many infidelities mostly
consisted of lashing out and punishing
his many wives and many many children
but eventually she must have reached the
point where the only solution was to
remove Zeus and thus the coup began in
order to overthrow Zeus Hera would need
assistance and that came in the form of
Apollo Poseidon and Athena who
themselves desired the throne Homer does
briefly mention that he thought Poseidon
was capable of overthrowing Zeus by
himself but he chose not to because he
did not care for the throne so it's
clear that he believes that Poseidon is
more powerful than Zeus in some versions
of the story Hera would drug Zeus to
induce a deep sleep and in
other versions the sleep was much more
natural the other gods then chained him
to where he slept and began arguing as
to who would take his place each one
believing that they were best suited to
rule the only deity not to take part
towards Hestia who did not care for
things such as power the mother of
Achilles Thetis had made it previously
known that Zeus was the rightful leader
of Olympus and if anyone else was to
take the throne then chaos would ensue
whilst the bickering between the
Olympians continued Thetis did the only
thing she could and sent a message to
brightest the biggest and strongest of
the Hecate inquiries asking for his
assistance
the Hecate inquiries had long remained
friends and allies of zeus for it was us
who freed them from Tartarus and allowed
them to obtain their revenge upon their
Titan brothers and sisters the cause
from Thetis would not go unanswered as
breas climbed Olympus and destroyed the
chains that bound zeus now at full
strength and with the most powerful
Hecate on crete by his side the other
gods and goddesses had no option but to
kneel before zeus and accept their coup
was a failure Athena being Zeus his
favorite managed to escape punishment
but the others did not share this
fortune Apollo and Poseidon was
sentenced to hard labor where they were
forced to help build the walls of Troy
and the punishment of Hera involved her
being thrown into the void and suspended
in the sky of anvils hanging from her
ankles where she would remain staring
into chaos until she took a vow sworn
allegiance to Zeus once again needless
to say after this failed coup Zeus's
leadership would never be questioned
again over the years there were several
attempts to overthrow Zeus some of these
came from outside Olympus and the event
we've just discussed came from those
that Zeus trusted the most but all of
them unsuccessful and it appears that
Zeus was able to break the cycle of
surrender and power and been overthrown
by your children personally I think that
Zeus was the rightful leader of Olympus
and I know many people may disagree with
me but without Zeus and he's many
shenanigans Greek mythology would be a
far less interesting place if you would
have preferred someone else to take the
throne than let me know who along with
your reasons why in the comments below
as always I've been your host mythology
and fiction explained